they called it the rose Revolution when
Georgians threw off Russian domination
led by a young politician called Mikhail
sakashvili
[Music]
not a single shot people overwhelmed and
really really removed the government by
a peacefulness when Moscow sent tanks
into Georgia five years later he led the
fight back against Russian aggression
and became celebrated as a hero in the
West
but this was Mikhail sakish Philly last
month looking Ashton and gaunt in a
court appearance by video link from
hospital and barely able to walk
outside the hospital his lawyer told us
he may not have long to live
it's an awful scene he looks like a
prisoner in a concentration camp in the
Nazi Germany jailed on abusive power
charges sakish Philly's supporters say
he's been poisoned Behind Bars we were
denied access to interview him in
hospital he sent handwritten answers to
our questions instead
in one he said he was four kilograms
from multiple organ failure according to
his doctors having lost half his weight
and he had a message for the people of
Georgia in this time of unrest stay very
Vision be ready to mobilize at short
notice
because of the vengeful mood of the
oligarchs regime
the warning followed days of mass
protests in Georgia against proposed new
laws viewed by many as pro-russian the
issue has been seen as a test of
George's loyalty is it to Russia or the
West the government is now backed down
over that proposed law and the protests
have subsided but the fate of Mikhail
sakash Philly is also being watched
closely in the west as another key
indication of George's Direction
European Parliament says he must be
freed and hardened the Georgia
government says that might destabilize
the country the ruling party is standing
by that position his doctors say he
could face multiple organ failure does
the government really want that and all
that's going to mean for the way George
is seen in the world and George's chance
of joining the EU well uh definitely
Georgia wants to be seen
positively right but it won't be seen
positively if sakash really dies in a
Georgian Hospital well we do hope that
it is not happening and it will not
happen and his needs are properly
addressed but Mikhail sakash Philly's
mother says time is running out to save
him I am waiting for a miracle
uh maybe it's possible I don't know you
say you're waiting for a miracle
but do you think your son could die soon
if he doesn't get help
of course
it's inevitable
it's unfortunately it's inevitable
and it's that moment coming closer
it's already close it's already close
but I still hope
she goes to visit her son twice a day to
bring him food Poland and Ukraine have
offered to take him in and treat him but
for now he remains in Georgia and may
soon die here say his family unless the
government relents and lets him go